il s'agit d'un forum professionnel comme
il en existe beaucoup d'autres mais
celui ci a ceci de particulier qu'il
entend rassembler l'espace d'une journée
des start up française et des grands
groupes russes l'objectif favoriser les
collaborations sur des sujets innovants
fêtes et des rencontres donc entre
décors poète russe dont grands groupes
russes et des startups françaises
on a trente 30 est une start up
française qui ont fait le déplacement
pour rencontrer en speed matching des
corporate russe ils se sont tous prêts
inscrit à l'avance nous avons ils ont
émis des priorités de qui vous avez
envie de rencontrer et ensuite nous
avons établi des plannings les plannings
vont jusqu'à 18 créneau de rendez-vous
dans la journée donc ça fait une journée
très intense pour ceux qui ont tous leur
traîneau rempli parce qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer jusqu'à 18 groupes différents
l'an dernier celle inverse qui s'était
réalisé des start-up russes venus à la
rencontre des entreprises françaises
dans le cadre prestigieux du château de
versailles pour déjà plusieurs résultats
concrets nous avons déjà identifié une
quinzaine de contrats qui ont été
effectivement signé on a une start up
qui a déjà ouverts en russie dans france
pardon est installé son sa filiale en
france et plus globalement nous avons
aussi des grands groupes français qui
ont établi des partenariats avec la
russie suite à l'événement de versailles
cette rencontre s'inscrit dans le cadre
du dialogue de trianon né de la
rencontre entre vladimir poutine et
emmanuel macron au château de versailles
en mai 2017
vous savez comment elle été créée lors
de la rencontre de nos deux présidents
avec l'idée que à la suite d'une
séquence aussi riche pendant trois
siècles depuis pierre le grand eh bien
il fallait être à la mesure de notre
nos sociétés contemporaines c'est-à-dire
d'intensifier les échanges qu'on avait
de très bonnes filières qui marche bien
et qui stimule tous sortent des changes
mais qu'il faut aller vers les nouvelles
formes de coopération de rencontre est
notamment allé vers les sociétés civiles
on le sait je vais pas me lancer dans le
grand dissertation entre l'autonomie de
tous les réseaux les nouveaux modes de
communication et donc c'est un peu la
mission qui nous a été donné avec la
mise en place une plateforme numérique
et surtout à partir de là la recherche
de nouvelles formes des changes
de nouvelles activités qui disons le
sans cette touche supplémentaire cette
dynamique particulière du deuil de
trianon ne se ferait pas aussi aisément
c'est donc une application très concrète
de ce dialogue de trianon qui se déroule
ici se rencontrer échanger pour au final
mieux se comprendre et pourquoi pas
créer des opportunités
[Musique]